please welcome the recording artist who
made her brilliant acting debut in the
People vs Larry Flynt Courtney Love
the makeup artists have the power to
transform us from the cocoon of the
dressing-room to the butterfly of the
film giving the act of the confidence
and inspiration to play that goddess or
which or the extraterrestrial from deep
space
this year the nominees for best
achievement in makeup are for ghosts of
Mississippi
Matthew W Mangal and Deborah Lamia
denver used a rubber cap to begin the
processes of turning james woods into an
old man for the Nutty Professor Rick
Baker and David Leroy Anderson used
latex and gelatin to turn trim Eddie
Murphy into a blubbery sherman klump for
Star Trek first contact Michael Westmore
Scott wheeler and Jake Garber took nuts
and bolts to create the spectacular
creatures for the film
and the Oscar goes to David Leroy
Anderson for the Nutty Professor
thank you
we'd like to thank the Academy Universal
imagine Brian Grazer Tom Shadyac Jim
Brubaker
Julio John Landis I'd like to thank my
crew without their talent and hard work
David and I wouldn't be up here a huge
thanks to Eddie Murphy he made seven
rubber characters come to life yes he
was amazing yeah he made seven rubber
characters come to life sat in the
makeup chair for over seventy days and
he never once complained he's the most
talented and cooperative actor I've ever
worked with lastly I'd like to thank the
artist who was the first to inspire and
teach me my father Ralph Baker thank you
very much